well it may only be september but if  you're already in the halloween spirit  like so many of us then this is the  perfect thing for you the first ever  paranormal walking tour of boulder city  debuts tonight it covers a half a mile  loop in the historic district the tour  talks about the men who died building  the hoover dam the woman who became  boulder city's first murderer  a ghost dog that has haunts that haunts  the streets area 51 and what's called  the nevada triangle this weekend is  already sold out but of course there are  plenty of other tickets left the cost is  20 bucks for adults and 13 dollars for  kids 12 and under so much fun there